Dwight down
what's with the jeans you know
yeah it doesn't like who they should
have like naked chicks right yeah I mean
it should be a bunch of naked chicks
here's my dad hello oh good I'm glad you
like it yeah wait yeah yeah yeah he's
second big shits
he's like such a massive shit yesterday
on the big shakes
yeah Wow that's awesome
sometimes yeah and at his age now all
the shit's are really soft and it'll be
shit just all over his ball bag and and
all over his ass cheeks just little bits
everywhere yeah what's that oh yeah you
should take a lip of it now yeah I'm the
same way I don't care doesn't bother me
it doesn't bother me when he does it or
Christina does it I don't I let me do
that wait wait wait hold on hey top dog
she's right here
it's gonna ask you how did your cruise
go did you take good shits on your
cruise did you get to watch it oh good
he's the best isn't he I'm gonna send
you did you see his billboard but but
but don't you think he gets it from you
because you're your really good public
speaker - when you saw my when you saw
my spell did you come there's parts of
that we're not going to use